I choose to identify myself as a first
generation student because within my
immediate family I am the Trailblazer in
going to college I have no parent that
had any experience in the u.s.
educational system so for me I
absolutely consider myself first gen
first gen that wasn't a thing in terms
of language what people were using and
so I remember calling up my sister for
little things about you know signing up
for classes and how do you get involved
and just general support like how do you
talk to mom and dad about this stuff
what do I think about a major how can I
think about careers who do I talk to you
if I have a cold who you know all those
things that my peers seem to just
instinctually know I had to ask or I had
to figure it out you know I knew it was
really important for me to get connected
and build that Network on my own and so
I I did it was hard for me at first to
really break out and make friends one of
the goals of the first together
initiative among others is to build that
community and that networking and having
a group of mentors they can come and
surround you the most important person
in my undergraduate years that get me
over the hump was a professor who was
also a first-generation college student
she really just guided me and gave me
mentorship throughout the process I
think that without her giving me that
individualized attention and support I
would have been really really lost and
so she kind of sort of reinforced in me
that you know I was capable of getting
through college successfully and that
kind of stuck with me so it also set the
trajectory for my career I think it can
be intimidating as a freshman student to
you know like hear about oh my dad works
like a Google my dad is a doctor or my
mom's a neurosurgeon and stuff like that
and when you you're coming from a family
where you're the first one to go into
college that can be challenging can be
intimidating and I think knowing that
there are a lot of other people that
have gone through the same thing and
I've done amazing and great things it
can really support someone and in their
growth as a college student so I would
tell the faculty and the staff and
people administration here just come out
and share your stories get involved with
first together just some other time not
too much
their time can go a long way for
students on campus here you know coming
out to the meetings even just doing that
it shows your support and shows that
that you're in this with us and so
whether you become an ally and continue
to promote the initiative to other
people that will be so helpful as well
but we really need faculty and staff
because then they can connect with other
faculty and staff who aren't aware of
the first gen initiative or experience
or the identity so what's really
exciting is just to see the amount of
faculty and staff that has come out to
support the initiative and looking
around the room I was like oh my god
there's other people like me that are
also first gen in this community I'm so
students sometimes think that they're
the only ones that are looking for their
community of other people that identify
as first gen but I think as staff and
faculty we also look for people that
have had similar experiences to us so
it's nice to see other people that
identify his first-gen like myself and
that we're all really excited to support
the students
[Music]